[Music]
does anybody here uh believe in like
psychics or curses of course my life is
all about luck
i'm gonna say my life is all cursed
what kind
like a psychic like if you were to go
and see a psychic who were to
i tell you you'll have to say i was at
some pretty fun la parties and the two
times that a psychic was there because
you know they did that for fun they hire
a second to be there
they're like you're about to come into a
lot of money and i was like yeah right
liar and that's maybe one of the nine
things they say to people yeah was like
literally just before i like jumped into
crypto and all kinds of wow so i was i
mean is that recent or like your first
time this was like uh house party i was
in like 2015
just before or no it was 2016 just
before i bought into ethereum for the
first time at eight bucks wow oh did she
tell you the second part of the song you
told me to buy ethereum right now she's
like then remember to sell eight hundred
of them or whatever
before
i will [ __ ] strangle you right now
eight bucks oh yeah eight bucks ethereum
was at eight dollars he had like
hundreds of them i had like 800 of them
eight hundred ethereum how do you hold
that though
that's what i'm saying he didn't listen
to the psychics how do you hold that
that's impossible to hold if any of us
held the bitcoin and everything we would
have had like at least five mil oh yeah
especially if you're the type of kid
that's gonna eat the cookie first yep
800 ethereum i mean the dogecoin founder
[ __ ] sold all his dogecoin for a car
he did it
it's like three million dollars right
now
easily yeah
damn wow a uh california man
sues a psychic who said that she could
remove a witch's curse that was put upon
him from his ex-girlfriend and the chris
isn't out yet so he's like you didn't do
your job [ __ ] yeah well i think she's
also the one who told him that he has a
curse on him so that's the funny part oh
she set it up that's just good yeah
that's the symptoms of the curse there's
california l.a psychic that he paid for
fraud because she allegedly claimed she
could remove a witch's curse put on him
by his ex-girlfriend for fifty one
hundred dollars that was the price that
she had quoted holy [ __ ] last month this
dude mauro restrepo uh found the psychic
sophia adams website that billed her as
a phd as a life coach and a psychic love
coach according to the city news you
could get a phd in life coaching yeah
phd for anything nowadays really just
giving those things away huh
[ __ ] them as long as you pay the loans
right
or at least get the loan that's devry
dude
this made the plaintiff more confident
that he was speaking with a professional
a phd that could help him uh and then
the lawsuit was filed actually uh
recently friday in torrance so uh that's
a player-hating degree the psychic adams
gives uh restrepo a tarot reading when
he visited her office in palos verdes
okay
uh and told him that he had mala suerte
or bad luck
oh we're talking about bruja
bro dude i want a malasada
so uh adams allegedly claims that his
family would be unhappy and in danger
unless he paid her the 5100 to remove
the curse
and then restrepa reportedly paid adam's
a thousand dollar deposit but she did
not help in any way with his marriage at
the time because it's not fine
he has to pay the 5 000 for it to go in
effect like that's like everyone knows
that yeah you can't just put a deposit
down and [ __ ] it's like when we get
paid to perform right we get we get a
part as a deposit and when we're done
with the performance then we get the
other one in like 90 days exactly but
when you get deposit you don't perform
you don't you're just committing to
perform you're committing yeah so so she
didn't
he she didn't do the full seance or
whatever she needed energy that is going
into this
the money is a necessary component to
that because the money has the power yes
so you know why it didn't work it was
less than it was like barely twenty
percent of the energy
half committed yeah thousand dollars
worth of energy
regardless he says he suffered anxiety
and sleepless nights and is also suing
for intentional and negligent infliction
of emotional distress along with
negligence and civil conspiracy
sleepless nights how's he expecting to
get his curse lifted if he didn't pay
the full price he's going to get a full
curse and also how do you prove i know
he's a half curse yeah he's lucky how do
you prove your sleepless nights are
caused by [ __ ] witchcraft that's hard
to say but there's definitely an
objective dollar amount he's asking for
25 000 in damages so for sleepless
nights you know this is a case of a
scammer trying to scam a scammer
no this is a case of a psychic who
didn't see something coming
there's going to be a lot of jurors that
would let him that's a good one like
she's not that good obviously i think
that we got one of those fakers one like
like a mall santa yeah not exactly the
real the real deal hello
god that's so much better than anybody
laughed at
that's really good mala santa that's not
what i said i said maul santa
i said something worse oh
what's a mala santa yeah i don't even
know what's going on
i thought you were going there and i was
like man that was you know he's a loser
[Laughter]
yeah what do you think of that
was that much of a [ __ ]
hack gave him credit for a good joke
that you kind of came up with your own
roasting i'm not gonna [ __ ] swear
take this fool's dick right now dude i'm
scared of that you've already threatened
to make out with me last week
oh son of a [ __ ] damn it has anybody uh
is anybody into like [ __ ] tarot cards
and psychic readings though nah that's
just hella fun though right it's fun
it's fun
what's up with tarot cards i don't
[ __ ] [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
he had a tarot card lady
on our podcast and she was like super
accurate on [ __ ] it was pretty fun wow
what was something she was accurate on
uh she was just like talking about our
like what was going on in our life at
that point like and she didn't know us
at all like we just like literally found
her in like some kind of a um through
our agency yeah and she came and like
was talking about her current life
situation like what was going on all
different things and like she was
nailing all this [ __ ] but isn't it part
of the trick of tarot cards like they
say like kind of half truths so you
could attach your own meaning to it
absolutely no you will be putting on
shoes
sometime this week you will be putting
on shoes
uh i'm feeling like you won't be wearing
something like a t-shirt
you're like yeah oh [ __ ] we're the
teacher right now they do say things
like you know i feel like there's
something that you're really trying to
accomplish and there's just that one
thing that's holding you back but you
kind of know what you're going to do to
get over it and i feel it's coming and
you're like but that applies to
everything it'd be doing the launch
that's pretty good
should be a psychic you don't read tarot
cards [ __ ] got me there i'm just
waiting for the next part of all season
just look me in the eyes and then just
say anything right now and i'll see if
it genuinely will will relate give me
anything one day you'll grow up to be a
real dancer
dude [ __ ] this guy
hey look at me
grow up [ __ ] kinses
imagine you went to a psychic
that's impressive if they didn't know
that they were yeah they didn't know
anything oh they said i don't know
anything i'm seeing a [ __ ] kinjas
there's a friend just is very strong
they're like [ __ ] just i was like
damn steve is my friend yeah
how did you know steve steve's been
saying this for a year have you guys
actually went to a real real psychic
though to like get your reading or
whatever what did they have neon lights
in front of their house no oh the one
off the [ __ ] five
oh it's a punch that was weird there's
one over there [ __ ] the one next to
the seven eleven dude my dad's good
that little house my dad's been there
never had a business man let's go all
right now how come they all believe in
the same security it's the same half
fence with little spikeys on it and it's
all white fence yeah and in the it's
their living room that's the place of
business with the neon light yep but
then they live in the back house yep you
always gonna walk all the way the next
yeah there's no front door i never went
i'll let it for jesse here [ __ ] hinges
at the end
75 bucks for that you know
i said that i don't want them to be like
you're gonna go through a [ __ ] car
accident so then you think about it you
manifest i know that's all i've been
getting ever since i was a kid because
my mom gets her [ __ ] read all the time
i'm like shut the [ __ ] up i'll be like i
want to create my own [ __ ] destiny
with my own thoughts not yours you son
of a [ __ ]
don't tell me how rich i'm gonna get no
no no no i don't care two million no no
i want have a i just want half a million
shut up
some weird sidekicks bro
you thought how to get a word in two
million
and i'm like oh [ __ ] those are your
thoughts
joe has strange motivation yeah
now i don't want too much i don't want
just enough
are you sure
i've seen you operate much differently
yeah yeah what is it now everything
about your life tells us differently
it's much more aggressive than you let
on my friend
oh what do you mean
what else do you mean yeah exactly i am
a very conservative person
i think so sometimes
some of the questions that you ask about
crypto i'm like this fool doesn't even
know what the [ __ ] going on and he has
so much money in i'm like this guy is a
[ __ ] legend
he's like what is this one and he's like
how does it work and he's like okay i
just put in and then he shows me his
phone today and i'm like
[Laughter]
he's a he's a [ __ ] mad man dude
you're [ __ ] there's a lot of zeros in
the percentage sign that that made me go
ah
money time
i was like play money only and joe's
like this is some fun money isn't it i'm
like
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you're a dude yeah you're the
psychic now yeah dude this is the guy
he's [ __ ] he's pretending i told i
told bart that i get anxiety when i have
money in my bank account exactly
she's not a half measures guy